Now you've heard the term thread. Well, it's
also used in the context of an operating
system. What is the difference between a process
and a thread? An analogy will help here. Let's
say here is the morning newspaper. This morning
newspaper lying on the dining table is like a
program in memory. No life. I come to
the dining table, pick up the newspaper, and particularly
the sports section of the newspaper and start
reading it. My starting to ready the sports section
of the newspaper is akin to the operating system,
giving life to the program by starting to execute
it. So, now there is one life in the program. That is one line of control, that
is coursing through the core and data structures of
the program. This is what is called the thread
of execution through the program. So we
have one thread of control that is coursing
through the program just as I am reading.
A section of the newspaper. Now, my wife
comes along, and being the more responsible one
in the family picks up the business section
and starts reading it. That's perfectly fine, depending
on our interests, I'm reading the sports section.
While wife is reading the business section, each is reading a different section
of the same newspaper. similarly, we can
have multiple lives, coursing through the program.
Each blazing a completely different trail through the code and data structures
of the program. Now each of this is a thread of control. Now could there
be a conflict between these different threads
of control? Sure. Both my wife and I
may want to read the same section
of the newspaper. That's a conflict. Similarly. The
threads that are executig whitin the same
program may wana read or update the same
data structres. These are the issues that
the operating system has to deal with, and
this is what I meant when I said that te operating system is the
orbiter for copleteing reqests for rescorces. Now
generalizing it. A program can have several threads
of control, and each thread of control
maybe coursing through different sections of the
program. And it could also be competing for the same section of the program as
well as the same data structure in order to manipulate. Thus, a process. Is a
program plus the state of all the
threads that are executing within the program. Just
as a single newspaper could be shared by me, my wife, and possibly my children.
In a similar manner, a program may
have multiple lives. That are coursing through it.
And each is a bit of control, and the process is the program
in execution, meaning it is the program plus the state of all the
threads that are currently executing within this program. For example, if
this program. Is a web browser. One thread in this
program, could be fetching a page that I've requested from the
remote server. And another thread could be painting the screen for me.